[Music]
it's sex upgrade news yes please I dare
you the bathroom right better start
[ __ ] in there right now yeah you will
perdu where she wanted to [ __ ] when
we're at a sports bar yeah that's worse
bro a bar no this sports bar the
bathroom is that a toy it was not you
know what cuz you're thinking of the
guys bathroom I was thinking of the
women's bathroom we were in the bathroom
during I remember the bathroom around
nuts in there the bathroom here doesn't
smell like piss and [ __ ]
exactly I'm being mean to those less
people that could catch you exciting and
you don't want to be caught by your
friends yeah yeah that's like family a
new self lubricating condom design may
help to encourage safe sex it's not
about the lubrication it's about the
feel they'll never get it it's not about
the situation in the bathroom it's about
getting caught that's exactly know you
have to say though when I'm about to
bust a condom comes in handy
that's good Randy exactly supposed to do
it well I mean experts are saying that a
big turn-off for condom use is the lack
of lubrication you know what I like
about condoms cuz we never used them
because I was always on the pill so we
just started using this year like during
the fertile okay it feels like it's a
strange job here you always use a condom
is ls0 the street check it's like you
might as well I just stuck your dick in
the freezer before you start a fight
it's exactly right use a dull know
doesn't feel human but it feels like
we're being bad I'm hooking up with a
stranger no wait I'm [ __ ] room temp
now oh yeah because normally it's very
hot but then it's like it's like room
temp in here am I gonna see if there is
there's the loop warm up is that no so
now scientists say that they have
I like outside they have warming Lube
you know
yeah that's time yeah so there's Dave
they've developed a condom that becomes
slippery when wet
Oh itself slippers yes without
lubricating wet it's still a sweaty
condom don't keep the slipperiness
longer than latex condoms that have Lube
in also tell latex it's not a disgusting
yeah what's the matter
it's a sweating condom not that there's
this like thing that they've put over a
regular condom that creates it's a layer
or is like a coat it's like a coating
reason why I'm saying that is because
they are saying that hopefully
eventually they want to be able to sell
whatever the thing that they developed
to condom manufacturers so they don't
have to change up their developing thing
is just like an added layer at the end
it's like a stamp so like when you lick
it
it changes the chemical compound of it
it changes the yeah that's what I
picture too like a stamp or yeah like
once it gets wet it like changes the
exactly it's something like that I wish
there was something like by the way safe
sex is always important stuff my condoms
suck and I love trojan Wow oh it's like
that here's the thing well it's not
finalized brain deal yet is it so you're
already promoting them before it's a
good business woman about it you know
what I wish though already sign the
contract David you blew your load bro
trojan makes magnums right yeah they're
the brand that makes man there's not
enough options within magnums like they
don't have ribbed magnums they don't
have the extra thin magnums they only
have one Magnum can we please get some
options now that I have to suffer
through this three men here cannot
relate so I have a very very average
penis I don't even know girls like the
ribbed and all those other ones question
that'll wear them we have to do have
some variety and I just have no question
what so I was reading that a lot of
people like they have the wrong size
condoms I didn't know condoms came in
different sizes
other than Magnum oh what's like the
small
medium irregular LEDs name differently
like I don't feel like they caught the
smell awfully different sizes just
regular sizing that extra life I was
reading this article and they were
saying that like some men like when they
put on a regular condom he'll be like
loser or whatever I was like what the
[ __ ] that happens if you never had that
issue before yeah that make sense of
anything wrong I used to use this
directs one and that [ __ ] was a way to
snow [ __ ] just popped off I
[ __ ] hated that [ __ ] Hugh braggers
average but that durricks one I don't
know it was a smaller one though what do
they call it though yeah I don't
remember I just grabbed it could you say
it was a little thinner snug that [ __ ]
was not normal-sized it on a snug fit
petite petite it depends on where you
buy it all over the world - really
smaller it's like clothing sizes for
women like our America yeah these sizes
like our - is like England 14 we're just
fatter out here it should be because
it's less material for smaller next that
should be way cheaper well I mean they
say the same thing for clothes and then
they get mad roll it should be mark
because you wearing way more clothes but
think about it if you buy more fabric
right it's way more fabric it's the more
expensive and produce so we would you
would have to pay more for clients I get
it you for paying more for condom I get
it I'm just imagine Matt I need to pay
more for college that should be don't
larger shirts cost more yeah hell yeah
not always Oh manufacture it does yeah
because there's more fabric right but
then when it gets released out onto the
streets an XL in excess it's because
they have economies of scale so they're
just gonna buy they if like they've got
a fat population you're gonna buy like
10,000 fat people shirts then it'll get
cheaper and it'll balance out but if you
don't have any small people
[Music]
you really gonna roast this me what it
what is it like big and tall that's
that's well you should know when we had
go for broke yeah when we had go for
broke a lot of people rested how come
there's no quadruple XL shirts well
first of all quadruple x oh my god and
this is coming from a fat dude so a
second of all like it's so what happens
is it's like the economy we don't have
that many people so a lot of
manufacturer
Excel stuff same thing with girl clothes
too right like there's an extra special
small [ __ ] it was also more expensive
for us to make out a lot of people I
didn't do ladies cut it the most like
closest to like whatever your market is
medium XL and small or the ones that we
had on most and then we had double XL
and even double XL was more expensive
yeah it was you wouldn't sell it up like
it was like cheaper and it made sense
that we could get in small quantity why
not yeah got it but the small quantities
it doesn't match out with your like how
much you would sit there for ages and
then you'd have dead stocks god we can't
get 400 shirts for one person you know
because then we lose a [ __ ] ton of money
this is what sense you know anyway we're
talking about condoms here that it's all
business related now that's what we need
to talk about with this news that makes
it a slippery slippery earth wouldn't
you lose the friction though like cuz
that's thinking that I don't like water
sex for that reason I don't like period
sex for that reason cuz it's too too
much snug it moist snug it market
tighter like it's too wet it's like
[ __ ] a bathtub yeah try that before
you [ __ ] about those we try to [ __ ]
everything about this a little too hard
you know like [ __ ] in water you can't
[ __ ] the shower very well because
that liquid it doesn't lube it up it
dries its water is worse you have to
like use Vaseline Juris they always say
its dangers like if you get some water
up in there some [ __ ] can happen really
yeah that's why you're gonna do it as
soon as you get in there don't try to
favor it just bang it out real quick
while it's still kind of moisten not to
water it does that happen in the jacuzzi
- probably definitely yeah I don't want
to [ __ ] Jew
here's a gross though water up inside of
me know that I try to wonder you know
what I don't feel sexy it wasn't my
favorite but the sexy part was that
you're not supposed to do it well like
how could you guys I don't want to get
god thing you have to use Vaseline
what the [ __ ]
yeah because otherwise have you done
that yeah no I mean you dress well you
don't do much besides the bedroom do you
what is that bring your boxers into the
jacuzzi it's all weird as [ __ ] yeah
that's true well you know the day that
we [ __ ] outside of our bedroom I'll let
you all know the sweat trucks has the
[ __ ] little Coco fine oh yeah that's
brilliant
yeah yeah yeah but then the velcro's
like scratch up against no it was more
just like you know the water thing like
you were saying like it's hard to put it
in there what's the sin yeah well I was
trying this one is that the Merial
official review if it was a nude beach
and everyone else was nude would you do
it then would I be nude [ __ ] out a nude
beach I don't know I was supposed to do
that a new beach I think I feel like a
pretty strict on rules because of the
people that think sexual thing
deliberations yeah exactly
that's what new beach people say you're
not a lot to go consensual yeah I just a
random person talk about random people
like you sound like Bart right now yeah
you do okay at Mardi Gras right yeah
when they go they just want beads it's
like a strip club rules right let's
listen
yeah exactly strip club rules do you
understand that but I'll tell you a
secret
they let me touch their boobs what they
bring their hands up to you then yeah
yeah I don't say anything
consensually is fine consent the consent
is always fine how long touch a stripper
in 2018 I wanted to touch her boo oh
that's good yeah good to know I want to
yeah
that's very good good good job Steve
won't do it that's right he won't do it
well you guys anything
it left end zone I got one but he yeah
they did it for America I got it for
everyone you don't remember that [ __ ] I
told this girl you stay there and you
get both of them yeah yeah yeah it was
always because I didn't know where to
put my hands I'm yeah me too I'm like
I'm not turned off by this so I don't
know what to do I knew where to put my
hands but I am but I also knew not to
not to do he just like wanted to do yeah
yeah girls aren't doing it for you
they're like doing it to turn on your
man and a fella that kind of felt weird
they're like isn't it hot to your wife
and another girl are here you want this
too badly for me it puts up big al
sexualities on a spectrum and um I think
the majority of people are a little bit
more vibe not me yeah I was a strip club
with a girlfriend one time and the
stripper was in my lap and she was
telling me about how she wanted to [ __ ]
me and my girlfriend in the back and
that she would do it for money and her
breath was so bad that I was like
nothing it was not we you if her breath
wasn't bad you would have been like okay
oh yeah yeah I wouldn't uh we didn't
figure it out yet they probably wouldn't
tell you till like way after exactly my
friend was at a karaoke bar with the
hostess and she was on his lap and
giving him a lap dance and talking to
him about ancient China that would get
you off you would love that I know
that's cuz she's trying to pay for
college dude she's like somebody needs
to go back in for tell me more about the
mean guy these flashcards I [ __ ]
grind on your dick please
[Music]